if it happens i will be watching cnn
intently and i never thought i would say
that
but how do you see the rest of america
responding to this because a lot of
people are pointing to
potentially even a bigger conflict look
what they did look what they did in uh
january 20th 2016.
2017 sorry 2017. yeah they went around
yeah yeah we were we were both there and
they went around burning they they
torched at immigrants
you know that poor that poor
working-class immigrants limo he would
he
had his own limbo as a contractor he
would give people rides they torched it
that was a very
famous site as well as the garbage can
that was on fire with the rest of the
mainstream media around it but it's
because they're like limousines are for
the rich and it's like
it's some poor guy who leased it to run
a business to drive people around he's
not rich they don't care
so if look man i'll tell you this if
trump does find a way
to flip this i'm boarding up my windows
man and i'm in the middle of nowhere
okay i'm not really gonna board up my
windows but uh i don't think you need to
uh not out here but uh we we we went to
the we went to the armory
the other day yeah yeah of course luke
and uh yeah we went there and
uh uh that was really fun bottom out yes
uh
it's very important to be able to defend
yourself and have the right to defend
yourself
a lot of politicians have a lot of
security guards with machine guns and
guns around them
and they think that they could afford
themselves protection but you
shouldn't have any protection at all
which is absolutely ridiculous and i
think
one of the core strengths of the united
states that makes it as
special as it is right now is the
ability of individuals
to be able to arm themselves the second
amendment is extremely important and i
think
we're heading down a very dangerous road
rather
whether donald trump wins or whether
biden comes in
and then tries to restrict that right
take away the right of individuals to
defend themselves
i think it's going to be a very big
clash point between americans saying
no this is absolutely not okay we had on
destiny the other night and i think
one of the arguments he brought up is
the perfect example of why
joe biden thinks he's completely
justified in stripping away your rights
when uh destiny he's a leftist
mentioned that we need a two-month hard
lockdown and the government should
support people i said
don't people have rights his response
and this is something i've heard a lot
from the left
is do you what do you have a right to
drive your car drunk
and my response is you don't need to
drive your car drunk
you do need to make a living and work a
job and and run your business and pay
your employees like
those are things you need to do yeah
yeah so so that's completely different
yeah it's totally irrelevant but think
about how democrats that's how they
think
they're like you can't drive your car
drunk why would you go outside and get
someone else sick and it's like
because we have to well but you need to
eat but you can't steal food if you
can't afford it
you don't have the right to steal food
if you don't have enough money for it
what does that have to do
if you need to eat but you don't you
don't have a right to steal but we give
people food we have food banks we have
we have welfare cards
sometimes we literally no no everyone
has access to that stuff
well they're just saying it's a
technicality but
like you can go to food banks you can
get ebt cards i think i think every
state has
has an electronic benefits system so
if you steal food when you can go to the
department of human services
and you know we have welfare programs
it's very different from getting drunk
and driving your car
not only that you know what the penalty
is for stealing food
typically slap on the wrist yeah the
penalty is for driving drunk
yeah it's dangerous yeah it's a felony
you can't drive anymore you go to jail
you get ankle bracelets it depends on
the state of course some states are more
severe than others
for sure but there's there's there's
more here we got just just
oh you know before we go on i got
evidence about this dnc
telling trying to trash bernie for being
jewish
yeah it's an email this is from politico
uh from the dnc
cfo brad marshall sending it out to a
bunch of dnc
uh people and it said uh it may don't
read it don't read it verbatim if
they're trashy no it's nothing nothing
that you can't say online but it's cruel
that they would do this it may
um it might may no difference it's a
typo
but for kentucky and west virginia can
we get someone to ask his belief does he
believe in a god he had skated on saying
he has a jewish heritage
i think i read he's an atheist this
could make several points difference
with my peeps my southern baptist peeps
will draw a big difference between a jew
and an atheist
marshall wrote in a message to several
dnc communication directors
so we we we have uh there's a lot to
talk about right so
there's a reason why i highlight uh
georgia and
trump's attorneys asking georgia's
legislature to overturn the election and
select their own electors because we
have we have this going on right now
supreme court again is asked to block
biden in pennsylvania
justice alito has given let me read it
they say
in a sign that the case okay let me stop
this is act 77
it is the no excuse mail in voting the
absentee expansion in pennsylvania
several republicans and uh brought
brought the suit to
uh the courts the lead plaintiff mike
kelly
won his election if they overturn or the
judge's rule this election was
unconstitutional
he causes damage to his own career that
was noted by the judge
they're saying that no excuse mail in
voting is a violation of the
constitution
it was thrown out by the pennsylvania
supreme court on narrow grounds that
sorry you took too long to file but in
the uh lower court's ruling they said
that these republicans will likely win
on the merits
and what does that mean i don't know it
could nullify pennsylvania outright
well they've filed to the supreme court
and alito they say
in a sign that the case is likely too
late to affect the election
justice samuel alito ordered the state's
lawyers to respond by december 9th
a day after what is known as the safe
harbor deadline
that means that congress cannot
challenge any electors named by
named by this date in accordance with
state law
state law is irrelevant to the
constitutional process
the the constitution says the
legislature decides how the elections
are run
and who the electors are internally the
supreme court can complain about the
legislature but what the legislature
says to the federal government in terms
of their electors is an entirely
different matter
more importantly it's really interesting
because i'm seeing
two messages from the left they're
saying if
alito supreme court justice has ordered
the the the state
to answer by the ninth that's after the
safe harbor provision meaning
they didn't uh bring the dispute in soon
enough therefore
the electors are certified case closed
biden wins
but that makes literally no sense i
actually have from congress.gov
it says december 8 2020 the safe harbor
deadline the us code provides that if
election results are contested in any
state
and if the state prior to election day
has enacted procedures to settle
controversies or contests
over the electors and electoral votes
and if these procedures
have been applied and the results have
been determined
six days before the elector's meetings
then these results are considered to be
conclusive and will apply in the
counting of the electoral votes
okay based on my reading of that let me
let's ask it let's ask a few questions
they say
if if results are contested in any state
all right question are there results
contested in any state by
official governing bodies yeah
yes it seems like it of course yes i'm
just a newbie is it contested
yes yeah in michigan in nevada
in arizona in georgia in pennsylvania
there are active disputes
all right and it's prior to uh uh prior
to election day
interest and if the state prior to
election day has enacted procedures to
settle controversies or contests over
electors and electoral votes
have they does that mean general court
system
does that resolve the new complaints
that have come up relative to fraud that
happened after the fact
see this is where things get confusing
they say if these procedures have been
applied
has anything been applied to rectify
complaints about voter fraud from the
legislature
especially in pennsylvania who have
called for an emergency session
perhaps they would perhaps the argument
is because i'm not a lawyer the governor
has to call a special session
because he didn't there you go there's
there's there's you know no resolution
but now my question is this
what if the supreme court is saying we
want your answer by the ninth
some conservatives are saying alito set
a trap that
if they they now have to wait till the
ninth to issue their
you know response maybe they can do it
sooner if they do
then there is a dispute active the
supreme court requested a response
then wouldn't veteran just basically
avoid those electric
electoral college vote votes that's
that's the question here who knows i
mean trump
really wants this to go to the supreme
court because he knows he has the
advantage there
and he has a lot of prior lawyers that
were on the bush
team in the 2000 contested elections as
well we
that i mean that was contested all the
way until mid-december so how is this
going to unfold especially if the votes
aren't certified if this goes to the
supreme court who's going to rule what
it's 2020. i think anything could happen
at this point i think but it's very hard
to predict
i think it's the fact that the supreme
court is involved which makes this
questionable because
the way there's two ways people are
reading it and um
some people are saying if they're not
resolving this dispute and applying no
nothing to resolve the controversies
because they still exist
then they haven't met the deadline and
the elections in dispute but it says
my understanding is okay there's a
controversy
if the state has a way to resolve these
before election day which many of the
states do you go to court you file
lawsuits
and if they've enacted procedures to do
such many of these things have gone to
court and they've been thrown out or
whatever then it sounds like it's all
resolved
but the supreme court steps in and says
this is actually escalating
and if they have to wait till the ninth
and the supreme court hasn't chosen to
accept or dismiss
there's an act of controversy in
pennsylvania how could they then meet
that deadline
in fact it sounds like this actually is
bad news for democrats
because there's no way they can resolve
it if it's going to supreme court
unless of course they sue and argue we
it's irrelevant what the supreme court
says to us because the state has already
finished this
you know i'll put it this way there
there are legal experts who have said
it's not going to happen it's certified
it's done there's nothing they can do
about it the supreme court has
has no say right the way i put it is you
have to understand
that these are human beings who can
choose to rule and
and exercise that power like when the
other day when we're talking about
uh the ballot observation in
pennsylvania a judge
actually ruled when when trump's
campaign giuliani they were like
682 000 votes were counted with no
observer
and the judge is like were there
observers in the room and trump's
lawyers are like
well yes but they didn't have meaningful
access they couldn't look at the ballots
the judge said
well the election code doesn't say how
close you have to be
therefore judge or they're paid off
or or he's crooked so when you and then
and then the left cheers for it okay
i'll tell you what
if you're going to cheer for what is
obvious to any sane person a ridiculous
ruling
we know what observers are for there's
that you know you see that photo from
florida where they're like staring at
the ballots with the pen and pointing it
and make sure that people are counting
properly for a judge to be like well
they were in the room
the election code doesn't specify
distance so while
other ones were kicked out and not
allowed even in right so
you know but as long as there's one as
long as there's one that is
not what the intent of the law was so i
tell you if they can do that
if they can rule that way and the left
cheers for it then i'll tell you this
if if the supreme court takes this up
and then the
the the four liberal justices i include
roberts in that
versus the five and the five say we
don't care we're the supreme court
here's our opinion
boom it's done it's that's it and they
can say so
there's there's we got huge news look at
this we got a letter check this out
it's a huge letter i think what this is
this was posted to
uh well it's being shared around quite a
bit they say 76
members of the pennsylvania general
assembly they're basically saying
three usc 15 empowers congress to reject
electoral votes
that are not regularly given or lawfully
certified
the aforementioned conduct has
undermined the lawful certification of
pennsylvania's delegation to the
electoral college
for these reasons we the undersigned
members of the pennsylvania general
assembly
urge you to object and vote to sustain
such objection
to the electoral college votes received
from the commonwealth of pennsylvania
during the joint session of congress on
january 6 2021
we have pennsylvania state legislator
officially now
requesting from p.a house gop news
i'm i'm assuming this is legit we've got
all these people who have signed on to
this
if they have submitted this saying
straight up the results are disputed
we object how is pennsylvania going to
be counted properly and sick on january
6.
you're going to have republican members
of congress who represent districts in
pennsylvania saying
we have submitted this letter we reject
these votes deal with it
is that enough to get trump to win no
that puts biden at 286.
they need two more states well
even if so check it out if they get
pennsylvania and michigan then biden's
at 270 he wins
they get pennsylvania and georgia
biden's at 270 he wins they need
three states in order to make this
happen
it's actually not that hard to do which
is kind of crazy
it's possible but it's still a very big
uphill battle and there's a lot of
uncertainties and a lot there's a lot of
things that
haven't ever happened before when we saw
what happened in 2000 it was between
bush and gore in one state
and one state right and a bunch of
different counties doing different
things yes
and you know that was still extremely
complicated
this what all the other states
complicates it tenfold
and and now we're set into no man's land
where we never were before
there's still a lot of contention
there's even donald trump saying that he
might not go to the inauguration
he might hold his own event one day he's
saying he'll concede another day he's
saying that
he said quote if we are right about the
fraud joe biden can't be the president
that's that's an exact you know quote
there so there's a lot in the air here
and uh so so listen listen i've heard a
lot from the media that trump would stay
jacoon all this stuff but the media's
hysterical
trump derangement syndrome so i'll ask
you what do you think the chances are
that it's january 19th or whatever and
trump gives an uh
an address where he's like evidence of
chinese influence and interference
joe biden we've seen the math we've seen
the evidence he shows the videos he
shows the charts and then says
i refuse to you know to accept this
and trump's already got loyalists in in
key positions especially in the pentagon
what do you think the chances are well
he has some loyalists but
if you look at the trump presidency it
is mirrored
in individuals leaking information oh
yeah
and backstabbing him and crossing him
and you know vice versa there's a lot of
foul play within the establishment
against donald trump
that's definitely fair so donald trump
doesn't have the establishment he
doesn't have a lot of the hardcore
washington dc insiders he doesn't have
the media he doesn't have social media
he has a couple guys with trucks that
that ride around
with his uh flag on there but uh it's
it's an
extremely big uphill battle you know he
should have known better
because when he came in he took the
advice of a lot of these crony
rhinos yeah and so they were like yeah
yeah you know
you want sessions for you know for aging
you want you want uh
uh bolton he brought out henry kissinger
he sat down with henry
kissinger before he got elected he he
congratulated
he was like it was like he was going to
play ball with him a little bit exactly
and then they and then and then it was
knives out and they were all
grinning and trump thought that he could
come in and say okay i'll work with you
guys but we're gonna do things my way
they're like yeah whatever you say trump
and then they unsheath those blades and
then a couple we took trump a couple
years to finally be like
i really should have just fired everyone
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back
to check us out when we go live don't
forget to subscribe
hit the like button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time